it's great to welcome tom hartman back
to the program tom hosts the thom
hartmann program and is also author of
the hidden history series the latest
book in the series is the hidden history
of big brother in america how the death
of privacy and the rise of surveillance
threaten us and our democracy tom always
great speaking to you
hey david great to be here with you
thank you for inviting me so um
james gleick wrote this book the
information and one of the things that
glike writes in the book is that for as
long as there has been any communication
technology think
drums to communicate over long distances
in the african savannah there has also
been the ability to surveil
intercept
send confusing messages to trick those
wishing to communicate in that in that
method and you can sort of follow that
with every communications technology up
through today
when and how would you say that what we
might consider
the modern kind of surveillance and lack
of privacy apparatus really got going in
the united states
it was in the late 90s um
prior to 1996
the internet operated under the same uh
telecommunications rules as telephone
companies when this went back to the
nineteen thirties uh it to this day if
you're on a phone call with somebody and
it's actually being carried over cell
towers it's not a voip call it's not a
voiceover internet call um because the
rules for the internet are now different
but if you're talking to somebody on a
cell tower or on a regular phone
uh for the phone company to listen in
for the government to listen in for any
third party to listen in they have to
have a warrant there has to be a legal
basis for that intrusion
in 1996 with the telecommunications act
section 230
um said we're going to drop that for the
internet
so
uh that that's one piece of it the other
is uh or another metaphor that to kind
of explain where we're at
is that prior to 1996 the rules for
uh people who host sites on the internet
were very similar to the rules for
people who uh own
uh disco clubs you know dance venues
bars restaurants or you're in your home
i mean if you david were to put a sign
out in front of your house that said hey
big party on saturday come on in and
just leave the front door open and
you're sitting in your living room
saturday afternoon the sun's going down
there's there's somebody raping a woman
in the back room there's a there's a
bunch of people shooting up heroin over
in the corner uh there's a guy in the
other back room who's who's selling uh
illegal pornography and the police bust
in they would not only arrest all those
people they would arrest you as the host
of the party right you have a
responsibility for what happens in your
house that you know about
and that was you know i mean this goes
back to british common law back to
literally the 10th century
so section 230 of the telecommunications
act of 1996
said that's still true for your house
it's still true for a bar it's still
true for a restaurant it's still true
for a civic center but it's not true for
anybody who builds a house on the
internet and thus
mark zuckerberg became one of the
wealthiest men in the world uh he built
a house and he said hey come on in and
have a party and he largely ignored the
people who were shooting heroin in the
corner and selling you know i mean they
started they eventually started cracking
down uh obviously they were from the
beginning and on the obvious stuff but
even now there's just i mean you know
this new report that january six was
largely planned on facebook and this
isn't just a trash facebook i'm i'm not
you know he's playing by the rules and
that's the problem i mean you know
in when you have capitalism in a
republic
the job of government is to set the
rules so the capitalism can work in a
way that doesn't damage society
and
uh we have failed in that regard
so the
republicans during the trump era talked
a lot about section 230 and some of them
seem to think
that if the platforms uh um had greater
liability
for the content that was posted that it
would benefit the right in some way i
guess because they believed that the
left is regularly defaming and
slandering and so on and so forth but
they they seem to sort of misunderstand
the the true impact that changing
section 230 would have do they not
yeah i mean i think the rights embrace
of changes in section 230 came along
with donald trump complaining about how
he was being treated by social media
right um they thought somehow if they
repealed that part of section 230 uh
that you know a thousand flowers bloom
or something i don't know you know i
i've never seen the logic in it um josh
hawley actually wrote one of the better
books about the horrors of section 230.
um the last half of the book is
basically
mostly a screed about how liberals want
to destroy america but you know the
first part of his book is a really good
description of the problems and what's
going on and why
um and and you know you've got people
like ron wyden you know the my senator
here in oregon as one of the leaders of
the effort to change section 230 but it
is bipartisan josh hawley's on board too
um so you know back uh
in 1980 or 81 i started running forms
for compuserve nigel peacock who's still
my webmaster and i he lives in the uk
we were running forums we had like 30 of
them you know the ibm pc forum the
macintosh forum the uh jfk assassination
forum the ufo forum uh the adhd forum we
had a whole bunch of them and uh
compuserve paid us well i mean i we had
a staff we had about 30 people
volunteered they weren't volunteers we
we paid them who were working with us
and it was a it was a fair amount of
money that copyserve was paying us
because this was before section 230 and
they built this house it was called this
is before html this is before the web as
we know it today
and copy serve and aol were pretty much
the only game in town
and so because they had built a house on
the internet they had responsibility for
what happened in that house and so we
were the ones who were kind of the hall
monitors
and in 1996 when section 230 passed uh
basically they laid us all off
uh that was uh
they stopped paying us right
you could keep working but we're no
longer going to yeah um you know that
there's progressive conservative and
libertarian
perspectives uh in terms of opposition
to the sort of surveillance that that we
now know takes place but
they're they're sort of different
principles it's sort of like with flat
earth you talk to four flat earthers
they all believe the earth is flat but
for conflicting and sometimes very very
different reasons and progressives
conservatives and libertarians have
different reasons for opposing the the
practices that we see now can you talk a
little bit about the those different
perspectives
uh with regard to section 230 or just
more generally more generally with your
cn things well i you know i think to the
extent that
and and we're seeing this in particular
with the with uh republicans across the
country tightening the screws on your
right to vote
that uh the
the
for lack of a better phrase the police
state aspect
of because in my book uh i i basically
break out two kinds of big brother
there's the state big brother which is
what george orwell wrote about and then
there's the corporate big brother which
george orwell hadn't anticipated and and
which is actually at the moment far more
aggressive or at least you know the the
tip of the iceberg above i mean ed
snowden kind of showed us uh what
government was up to but
um
so
anyway
the right seems to be embracing kind of
the police state tactics with regard to
voting
and
and would be or generally are more
inclined to um
to
to
not so much embrace police state tactics
on the internet but to say that
um you know if if the billionaires who
are running big social media sites want
to do what they want to do they should
be allowed to do it there's just this
reflexive thing against regulation um
libertarians pretty much the same thing
i mean libertarians the this the the
libertarian party was a scam it was
created in the nineteen forties by the
real estate lobby as a way to provide a
a political cover
for basically deregulation of the
industry
and uh you know they they thought of it
as as uh as a scam themselves i think it
still is to a large extent
um
you know the idea that a country can
work with nothing but the military and
the police being provided by the
government and the courts
but i think most democrats are slowly
beginning to realize or understanding
my party metaphor really i mean this is
this is really what it is is that
um
you have to have
rules for the game you know the nfl
defines the rules for football
and if the nfl went all libertarian um
you know they they were all republican
as it were you know they could say they
would probably change their rules to say
well you know whichever team gives the
biggest contribution to the guys on our
board of directors gets an extra player
on the field throughout the game um you
know we can we can tweak things if
there's enough money involved and that
kind of thing
um
that's
sadly and and that's what they've done i
mean there you go rick scott's new 11
point plan promoting deregulation of the
of the polluters right because they're
big campaign donors to the republican
party
so um with regard to privacy in the
united states i i think the dynamic is
just very similar david
when it comes to um you know in europe
we've got the gdpr california passed the
consumer privacy act in 2018 so at least
people know what personal data is is
being collected about them
are are those types of laws
significant and impactful or do they
give people maybe some kind of false
sense that something is being done
they are significant they do have impact
they they uh this these are the those
laws are why when you visit websites
that want to do business in california
or in europe uh they will say well you
accept cookies right um it's it's like a
flag it's a way of saying well yeah
there is something going on here we are
sort of spying on you or keeping track
of you or you know or maybe it's just to
help your experience um and in some
cases it is actually
but in any case i i think that that's
that's something that we need to you
know really seriously look at is the in
particular the european rules and and
the one uh there's a whole chapter about
this in my book in europe that we
definitely do not have here is the right
to be forgotten
um this came out of a 2018 lawsuit
uh or maybe was 2008.
no
i'm sorry i'd have to look up the year
but you know uh there was a spanish guy
who discovered that whenever he googled
his name he had gone through a rough uh
divorce and bankruptcy back in like 1998
and
uh lost his property lost his business
and when he googled his name he was he
had a real low profile guy and when he
googled his name that was pretty much
all that came up and it looked really
bad on him you know and it was impeding
his ability to to uh to get a date and
and and and find a job
and so he he asked google to delete that
from their search you know uh
things that came up when his name was
put in google kind of laughed at him um
he sued in spain
and uh european court went along with
him and and now you've got you know this
this the right to be forgotten across
europe where if you don't like
uh what is being said about you on the
internet uh you can't necessarily always
petition individual websites to take
down the content about you but you can
ask the search engines to no longer
deliver it to people
and that's a pretty consequential thing
and i know a lot of people in the united
states probably very much appreciate
that particularly people who have been
the victim of of uh you know uh
what's the phrase for when
uh mostly men are outing you know old
girlfriends with porn pictures and
things like that oh yeah uh what is the
term for that i don't remember the term
yeah
yeah it's like revenge porn i think yeah
that's the phrase
yeah um so
anyhow
that's something that we should
seriously look at as well
if last thing i want to touch on if the
direction that uh things have been going
isn't resisted in some of the ways we've
talked about and that you write in the
book
what what's sort of at the at the tail
end of it i mean is it the direction of
like the chinese social credit system
you know everybody has some different
idea of what they believe would be sort
of at the end of this what what do you
think would happen if this goes
unopposed
we already have a business version of
the chinese social credit system and
there are companies that brag that they
have 10 15 20 000 data points on every
single one of us they know our most
subtle uh preferences they know if we've
you know for example if they're
providing information to a company
that's trying to decide whether to
answer your customer service call in two
rings or in two hours
uh you can tell that company if you have
recently browsed the website of that
company's competitors so are you one of
those people who's calling in and saying
hey i'd like that price match well you
get you get to wait two hours uh
or if you're a regular customer of that
kind you know just really really
granular data
and uh some of which could be used to
you know basically harass or embarrass
people as well as to increase the
profits of companies
so uh
and and and similarly there are
companies that specifically market you
know the this kind of social credit
score it's not just your finances it's
not just whether you paid your credit
card on time it's you know whether
you've ever been arrested for drunk
driving or whether you've ever been in
an altercation with anybody or you know
how you behaved online in some cases
they're selling this information to
employers they're selling this
information to landlords they're selling
this information to retail companies
they're selling this company to
companies you know just to cell phone
companies and airlines and everybody
else who get calls from customers
um
there's
the potential for uh abuse is
extraordinary and
i'm not saying that it's not appropriate
to do that you know if i was a landlord
i would like to know if the person who
wants to run an apartment to trash the
last one and let dog poop all over right
um
that's not unreasonable but uh
there there have to be reasonable limits
on this stuff and there are none right
now
the book is the hidden history of big
brother in america how the death of
privacy and the rise of surveillance
threaten us and our democracy the book's
author is tom hartman tom always
appreciate your time
thank you david it's always a great a
great honor and pleasure to hear be here
with you